she put her hand on my hand and she
looked me right in the eyes and way you
are not stupid and I was like thank you
[Music]
hi guys i'm jake on the hardest of days
are the days where you actually kind of
take away something for yourself and as
cheesy as it sounds the kids end up
teaching you almost as much as you teach
them i was directing the the miniature
version of Willy Wonka was called Willy
Wonka jr. we had you know kids who were
a little bit older kids were a little
bit younger but the preschoolers were
all supposed to be the own balloon buzz
as you can imagine getting a bunch of
preschoolers to do
Oompa Loompa do p'tee anything can be
really really tough but one of the Oompa
Loompas the lead
Oompa Loompa he recognized that stuff
was not coming together and that we were
just days away from opening this show
and like he clapped and got everybody's
attention airing one part of rehearsal
and there's kids everywhere they said
guys you get it together
we're the Loompas and we're gonna show
everybody how good we can be oh but in
the limping and from that point forward
I mean it's hard to say was it perfect
just not quite but was it significantly
better absolutely and I think what was
really amazing is seeing somebody step
up and not be afraid to talk to their
peers but also kind of have this
commanding presence for the last year
I've been in one classroom I was
basically the third teacher in a team of
three for the whole year and I always
knew that eventually they would fill the
team with a permanent teacher and that I
would leave to the substitute in the
rest of my Center and I've always been
kind of emotionally prepared for that I
like most Millennials and very
self-conscious and very anxious as a
person
and I it's easy to forget our self-worth
a little bit but when I was leaving this
classroom once they filled the team of
three after I had been there for a year
I was kind of like oh my god
starting a new chapter ah and it was
easy to get like really in my head about
it but then when we had my little
goodbye celebration I realized when
looking at 20 like tiny little
three-year-olds and hearing how much
they cared about me how much I care
about me too so that was really really
rewarding hey I'm Emily I'm a former
preschool teacher we had this thing at
our school we have like a little thing
of band-aids the band-aids were a very
special treat because everybody wants
the band-aids with the characters on
them a lot of times when there's a
boo-boo you go get a band-aid they get
to pick the character it usually fixes
it and it's a very very big deal I had a
time where I was I was like cutting up
stars that we were gonna paste on a hat
and I was busy and I was frustrated and
the irony is that these are like kids
scissors and I cut my finger like a
little bit I saw like a drop of blood
which wasn't a big deal but of course I
was like no like I don't want any of
these kids to see this and panic and cry
I'm like Emily's bleeding so I that kind
of like was shooting I covered it and I
went over to the sink to wash it and
then one of my sweetest little girls
actually did climb up on the stool
she knew exactly where the band-aids
were and she came up behind me and had
like a menu like she had like Elsa
spider-man
ninja and like a bear and she was like
family which band-aid do you want in
that moment like seeing that they could
apply my only lessons but just like
compassion that isn't necessarily that
comes from me it also just comes from
growing up and helping each other and
that like I I teared up I remember it
was very very tough for this one girl
she was having a really tough time we
had little leaders in our class for the
day and it was her turn to be the leader
and at every turn
things got mismanaged other people
thought that they were the leader so
they were able to go retrieve the lunch
bag baskets or they sat in her chair and
you could just tell that she was getting
really really frustrated but I could
tell by the end she was incredibly
disappointed because her day to be the
leader it had kind of been ruined and I
remember saying like I'm sorry that this
happened to you today I hope that the
next time it goes better and she looked
at me and she goes it's okay because now
I get to go home and eat cereal to me
that just reminded me that no matter how
bad stuff can really get no matter how
turbulent things become in life that she
recognized that she had a family at home
that she liked cereal that she was not
worried that she wasn't going to get the
credit for not being the best leader
that day and that it would come around
again in a few weeks my take away the
life lesson was just be yourself be okay
with it if you have a rough day you can
go home eat cereal try again tomorrow
there was once a moment very
specifically remember where we always on
the st. Patrick's Day we hide gold at
the school we let all the kids loose and
they go find it and they don't even get
anything for the gold they don't win
money then win prizes they just have to
find these rocks and just like pure
Nirvana joy on the kids face when they
find
and it's stuff like that that just like
so much fun and so much joy in little
things one time one child was kind of
having he was being very boisterous in a
moment and he was calling me stupid and
I was like oh but he was three he
doesn't know what he's talking about and
and his friend one of our other kids she
put her hand on my hand and she looked
me right in the eyes and way you are not
stupid
and I was like but it was so sweet just
the way that she that she was so genuine
and so sincere and I was like oh and it
made me realize like oh her her parents
must be doing a really good job at like
um teaching her empathy and teaching her
how others are feeling working with kids
is like wildly inspiring I used to do I
was like in charge of like the imaginary
play section of the day and the school I
worked at had this like stock score
soundtrack so it was like a bunch of
movie soundtracks so every day I would
put on this soundtrack and I'd go to
sleep gonna sleep yeah something like
right in the middle of the carpet I was
like go to bed go to bed
they're like the music would start it
was like and I would just like a league
that was like oh we're in a zoo like
what are you seeing there like I see a
dinosaur like I see a penguin one kids
like I see you later okay it's just like
seeing how young kids can imagine
together it's like so cute you know it's
a veil we're like on board yes there is
a dinosaur in that corner like yes we're
being attacked by bumblebees but they're
nice and like yes there's a race car
running through it you know whatever
they come up with it's just amazing to
see everyone work together and you're
like huh what if we all did that all the
time I think what is the life lesson
that I've taken away from working with
students is that you can just be
yourself and that that's an okay thing
preschoolers they don't have any
preconceived notions of trying to be
something else unless they're playing
pretend or wanting to impress somebody
or needing something so that they can
have status they just are who they are
kids have so much more depth to them
than I think people give them credit for
at the surface the world is made for
adults we don't realize that and it's
all it's easy for a kid to feel very out
of place or like they can't do anything
yet but a lot of these kids they're
they're people they're real they have
real feelings and real ambitions the big
takeaway from working with students and
being a teacher is that kids at their
heart and core are just themselves and
they're really not afraid to be
themselves and to stay like exactly how
they're feeling about everything and I
think as we grow older and we put up
more and more shells and we get a little
bit more defensive a little bit more
protective we get caught up in life's
minutiae kids can really bring it back
down and remind you that hey
everything's gonna be okay and tomorrow
we can all try again
just doing the best that we can being
our best selves is just being kind of
our most authentic simplistic selves in
some ways and that's a really beautiful
thing that I don't think anybody except
young kids in preschool can really tell
you
you
[Music]